[Musique]
et là c'était une version plutôt
familiale jeune public plus ludique avec
la musique et tout et moi j'avais aussi
envie de transmettre des choses michael
couzigou marmaille su le personnage en
mercal que ses impôts - personnage est
réparé il répare les peurs que je
voulais mallet plusieurs choses comme un
puzzle
donc il y avait mon souvenir d'enfance
donc un écriture personnelle avec le
texte de marie ndiaye la diablesse et
son enfant que j'ai pu adapter en créole
[Musique]
pour moi quand remarquable c'est une
super héros c'est ma super héros parce
que malgré tout la réputation voilà
qu'on lui a faites
on a cassé et où pendant cette époque de
l esclavage elle a survécu
elle est toujours là ce côté femme
oiseau voilà elle est dans les mémoires
après on en parle comme on en parle
chacun ont fait ce qu'il a envie mais
quand on creuse vraiment se rend compte
que c'était une sorcière donc pour moi
une femme libre cela signifie on a voulu
mallet en fait vraiment le nos univers
quoi musicale mon univers musical son
univers théâtral ces univers de conte et
puis essayer d'aller vraiment l'un vers
l'autre
la rencontre de deux univers donc ça
m'aidait sané les corps en mouvement
quoique différemment et dans notre
démarche
l'idée c'est de dire ben puisque la peur
c'est un sujet central à la réunion lé
ladi lafé il ya plein de choses qui le
plat peur de regard de l'autre qui est
qui qui qui commet qui inquiète quand
même les enfants et puis qui nourrissent
aussi une manière d'être
si on commence à des maillets ça par le
biais du compte déjà nous mêmes en nous
mettant en scène
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour les
jeunes publics pour les enfants
continueront à nous écouter
[Musique]
allez